this is unspeakable he's been doing
YouTube for 10 years and has 200 million
people who watch his videos every single
month we're gonna break down his
business and how he's going to go to a
billion plus let's dive in I have so
many puns that I want to say like
speechless unspeakable I don't I won't I
won't do any of those but I want to this
was an idea that air rack because he and
I were talking he's like dude you should
do this kind of like a mini series for
your channel talk with people with big
audiences like how would you think
through what opportunity to go after it
so I feel like so many people are just
like lost like what do I just like yeah
what do I sell there's so many options
like I could sell energy drink I could
sell germax I could sell these
conference tables like it's literally
endless yeah you could launch umbrellas
or you could launch Kleenex boxes that
are unspeakable unblowable
um one down and make money and so the
problem is that a lot of I feel like
YouTubers influencers see one influencer
do something make some money and then
think oh I'll do the same thing and then
end up with a massively under monetized
like opportunity okay we've got the
market here we've got the brand here and
then we've got different monetization
Vehicles like what is the thing that
kind of overlaps all three that works
really well so there's like three kind
of vehicles so you have unspeakable the
main thing the biggest thing it's like
driving all the revenue yeah and then
you have 0 to 60 which is a new business
that's actually why I'm here in Vegas
for SEMA it's an automotive shop paired
with content and then the third idea
revolved around a consumable product I
don't I won't say what we want to call
it yet because the names are still kind
of in the air unspeakable but it might
be it's not unspeakable but basically
what we I really want to build a company
similar to what Red Bull has because I
know so much about content and I know so
much about you know all these platforms
I could build a marketing company sell a
consumable whatever fits that like
target audience that I'm trying to
Target but and that's all primarily
driven off the Unspeakable channel right
uh I don't know I I probably want to do
like a separate channel for it just
because unspeakables kind of got its own
thing like it's for kids you know what's
the age uh I would say a large majority
are like 12 to 16. so right now I sell
merch for unspeakable but my idea was to
kind of launch like a toy brand
um and just see where we can go with
that we have talked about the energy
drink idea right yeah so that's what I
love but that would be that third idea I
don't know I just don't I don't feel
like it would fit the Unspeakable
audience maybe it would maybe yeah but
um they're just a bunch of kids and I
just don't you know like I wouldn't call
it unspeakable yeah if I was to launch a
drink no for sure well it doesn't have
to be exactly what I mean yeah yeah but
the other thing that worries me is like
so I'm unspeakable right the brand
revolves around me the question is how
long
can I be unspeakable yeah like you know
right right now I'm almost 25 years old
when I'm 13 years you know when I'm when
I'm 35 am I still going to be wanting to
do that
probably not
um like I've tied myself to unspeakable
for the past 10 years so I can't really
get rid of it I can't like hire some
other people to come in and just kind of
like change who I am you know that's
like if the rock was like oh I don't
want to be the rock anymore so I'm gonna
hire this guy like it just doesn't work
you know like I love the energy drink
for like the crazy all the stuff that
you're you know filling your house with
sand today I'm gonna be feeling my
entire Island house with sand Maybe I'm
Wrong right yeah it could it could fit
the Unspeakable audience but I want it
to like expand I want it to go to like
you know like skateboarders and
snowboarders and like I I don't want
just like kids that love ball pit balls
and Nerf guns to drink my energy drink
you know what I mean yeah I see the
original distribution base it's just
like the launch pad and the only thing
that keeps it going is new distribution
and the product itself being good enough
that people who are in the first ring
tell their friends and like that's the
part that most people [ __ ] up they're
like I'll just slap my name on this
thing it's white label I completely
agree I just know that I'm not going to
want to film
videos for the next you know 30 years of
my life like there's already plenty of
days where I dread videos I still love
them like they're so they're so much fun
but I I know in like I know when I'm 36
years old I'm not gonna be like oh yeah
I'm so ready to you know fill my house
with balls and yeah let's put on let's
put all the sand in I don't know if I
could see me doing it for that long but
when you start doing the car stuff isn't
that still gonna be video too
yeah but uh we're actually looking for
like co-hosts so I just want to be the
creative brains of the channel just kind
of like help Direction can we segue real
quick into the car shop thing yeah is
the primary motivator for the car shop
making money eventually franchise is it
to have like lots of locations or is it
just for content to have a spot to make
content so there's like three branches
to the business like you have the shop
uh you have the content side and then
you would have the marketplace side
which doesn't exist right now but we're
working on building it like Parts yeah
so like parts custom mods and things
like that yeah that I see being the
biggest part of the business I have a
lot of people that follow me that are
actually interested in cars because when
I first started my unspeakable Channel
like
six years ago older now all I did was
car content oh yeah so I started doing
car Vlogs I had like a GTR I went to
like car meets I like went on rallies
because uh at the time I just did daily
Vlogs I was just like yo guys this is my
life that was what the Unspeakable
channel was like six or seven years ago
and then you started seeing what was
hitting and the crazier [ __ ] you did
yeah yeah because YouTube like six years
ago was like Vlogs like Casey neistat
was like the biggest YouTuber and he
literally just walked around New York
City making really good entertaining
videos but it was just a day of his life
yeah that's what YouTube was you had a
bunch of other creators like Mr Beast
and other guys come in and they're like
okay this is the new YouTube this is
challenges yeah where people are like
all right survival this survive on this
so I was like I need to like change that
so that's where everything else came in
and so if we're optimizing around how do
we make you the most money short and
long term right and really more so long
term it's clear that you love this one
like I mean just from like your energy
when we're talking about it yeah and
this is just like your cash cow
perfect world is this didn't start just
from a business perspective yeah is that
you only had unspeakable you're making a
good amount of money from unspeakable
and AdSense every month of all the
things I'm going to do I'm going to
leverage the existing massive media
audience that I have and find one thing
that they can all buy and then that
would be all that you would do then we
have a phase out plan for you getting
out of so it's like okay next six months
or next 12 months you're co-hosting one
to three people who are with you in the
shows as regulars and then you just do
one of these and then they're leading at
most of it and you're making a couple
appearances and then
you fall off the table Yeah Yeah
unspeakable could transition to
something like
Red Bull when you think of Red Bull you
don't think of one person like you just
think of like crazy anything crazy yeah
right I still think that an energy drink
is not bad I feel like the energy drinks
Market is so saturated totally if you
put the same amount of attention to
making the product the way you do videos
where it's like how does it taste in the
beginning how does the aftertaste like
if you like if you were to break it down
at that micro level of really making an
exceptional product you're excellent at
what you do so like that character trait
will carry over you know what I mean if
you apply it to this so if we're
analyzing opportunity it's number of
units sold times gross profit potential
per unit divided by competitive mode
number of people times the amount of
money made so like for me we do deals
with a very tiny percentage of people
but the amount of money that I make on a
deal is significantly higher and so for
me that cross-section even though it's
itty bitty bitty still makes it worth it
for me right because for that small
person helping them go from 10 to 100
million is very meaningful yeah and so I
can help a tiny amount of people a lot
and then help everyone else for free
and so we just have to figure out what
that slice is
what do you like this so you've got the
car thing you dig that what else do you
dig like what is your what are your what
do your people know about you
I mean just
having fun with friends and just making
videos it's just kind of the whole vibe
of like yeah so you get money from
AdSense and whatnot but do you have any
other brand sponsorship deals like
Integrations into videos yeah okay so
which so what are those advertisers Nerf
Legos Elmer's Glue we've done some with
WWE okay Five Hour Energy pop Pockets
honey like the website yeah yeah a bunch
of like small mobile game companies do
they reach out to you do you reach out
to them they all reach out to us really
of opportunity Vehicles the game would
be by far number one it would hit the
most amount of the audience you'd make
the highest gross profit per User it's
operationally from a fulfillment
standpoint the easiest to handle the big
hard part is like building a software
game that's actually really good I've
seen so many YouTubers make games and
doesn't matter the following that they
have like if the game sucks the game
sucks the game sucks the game sucks like
I like the energy drink angle the only
issue with these though is that they're
cash eaters
which sucks
what I'm gonna say you may or may not
like so just take it for for what it is
how can you do more of what we're
currently doing
because like of the plays like I like
that one a lot High likelihood of
success right within your wheelhouse
like there's only a couple tweaks it's
like okay find the other co-hosts like
if you're like well that's kind of hard
it's like well so is building a [ __ ]
software company like it's all hard
right it's all hard but like this one
you know like all the other variables
you've got down I feel like doubling
down on the media might be the play you
could probably like tomorrow 5x how much
money you make just by building out the
sponsorship bar that's all that you have
to do I kind of limit my scale on
unspeakable because I have to be in all
the videos right yeah I have to figure
out who my co-hosts are and start
sprinkling them in seeing how the
audience reacts to them finding one or
two people that are three people that
they really like and then rotating them
in and to the point where ideally and
speakers will be a group two or three
people that are kind of like hosting and
leading things along playing off each
other characters right yeah so like
scaling the content that way because I
think the growth for the channel could
be so much faster we put out 52 videos a
year right we could put out 100
that are all the same quality of those
52 but it's just limits all my time
because you know I have to sleep
eventually but when someone pays you a
million bucks or whatever to do a year
of sponsorships it's like that goes
straight to your bottom line that is not
common like which is why media
businesses are wonderful business like
Warren Buffett had all of these
newspapers because it's media it's one
of the most profitable businesses on the
planet and you're good at it which is
hard what's the saying where it's like I
don't know who said this but it was like
if you're good at sales you can you know
make a million five million 10 million
but if you're good at marketing yeah you
can make billions right
um well there's Instagram from Naval
ravacon which is you only sell because
you don't know how to Market and you
Landmark is you know how to build a
product yeah and what's cool about your
product is that it is both marketing and
product it's one of the unique things
about the media business is that how you
Market the thing that you have is also
how you fulfill that thing that's only a
media thing like no other businesses
like that where the marketing is the
Fulfillment if we were to plan this out
and say hey if you could Forex your
income in the next four years would you
do it just from the Unspeakable income
well if the answer is yes then it's like
well then we could reverse engineer that
like that's super doable I would bet
that in that four-year span there is an
opportunity like somebody who approaches
you who's got another energy drink brand
is like we already have funding Etc and
we just want to face for it or we want a
brand to associate with and then you can
do a brand deal with that company but
you do it for Equity litmus test number
one is like you love the product the
road path for unspeakable now feels
pretty clear to me how do you feel about
that no I like it and then you also have
this car thing
even here building the the car parts
thing like that'll definitely make money
I like I like that as a business model
and if unspeakable didn't exist I would
say yeah just do that you thought about
it before you built it you were like I'm
gonna build the content arm I'm going to
monetize over here and sure we'll make
some money at the shop whatever if
that's a complete business model in my
mind and it makes sense because it's
fully integrated into the videos it's
like hey we just put this custom mod
thing on the lambo by the way you guys
can check it out I've got 20 available
first 20 can go get it on the shop side
I already have a partner so to kind of
run and operate the whole shop the shop
okay yeah the shop is what is going to
open first okay the content it's kind of
like whenever we get a piece of content
whenever we get access to the new
Mercedes that came out you know my main
role is just to kind of oversee like
Direction and making sure they're
creative is you know on point the
marketplace doesn't even exist yet if
you were to do the marketplace it would
take the same amount of energy and
attention and effort as scaling
unspeakable likelihood of achievement
lower than unspeakable yep upside about
the same you already have a partner
who's running the Ops that's good I
think all you need is just have somebody
who's Junior running the content who
wants to like Mentor under you which you
have I'm sure can find somebody who
would just like live with you and read
this stuff this is the main thing this
is the baby this is what you're the best
at I really want the best in the world
at do more of that and then the only
thing that you're going to attribute
over here you're dropping the
marketplace you have the partner to run
the day-to-day Ops is just somebody to
run the content for the car shop and
then you can sell sponsorships and
whatnot that'll go through there which
is actually kind of nice because then
this one starts to merge with the path
of this one so that your attention will
start to consolidate in terms of like
how you make money and how you think
through things but now it feels really
simple yeah
feel better easy enough yeah well both
all of these are hard this one has so
few unknowns based on what you already
have in the experience congrats so on
everything thank you so much yeah he's
right